[Music]
summer is over and everyone's heading
back to school so we're taking a look at
all the time celebrity kids have totally
slayed their first day photos
[Music]
our babies are beautiful jessica simpson
instagramed this adorable photo of her
little guy ace newt hard at work
preparing for pre-k
[Music]
and just like that jamie lynn spears's
daughter maddie is starting her first
day of fourth grade i only have 10
minutes in the morning to get ready
especially with kids and work and the
whole thing it seems jessica alba's
girls honor and haven already have their
morning routines down too
[Music]
then there's jennifer hudson's son who
already completed his first day like it
wasn't nothing
i have uh three teenagers
my boys want nothing to do with the
industry for candace cameron beret's
boys max and lev it's all about high
school and hockey high five
and ali landry's trio seemed to be
settling into their new community quite
nicely they even walk to school the kids
absolutely love it i'm not kidding you
but the adjustment wasn't so easy for
mama allie admits she totally cried on
marcelo's first day of kindergarten
getting my vitamins after all my tears
last night another tear-stained mommy
reality star kim zolciak who shared this
adorable family photo and revealed she
lost it when her son cash got out of the
car i'm doing okay now
[Music]
three o'clock can't come soon enough
[Music]